hi guys this is Rob from simply learn
and today I am going to tell you how you
can become a successful cloud computing
engineer now cloud computing is one of
those technologies that's rapidly rising
and with any technology that's growing
rapidly it comes with several job
opportunities for the people who are
skilled in it so before we get into it
let's have a brief look at what is cloud
computing cloud computing refers to
services like storage databases software
analytics machine learning artificial
intelligence and so much more all of
which made accessible via the internet
the cloud tech services market is
expected to grow 17.3% in the span of
2018 to 19 which means there's a growth
from one hundred and seventy five point
eight billion dollars to a whopping two
hundred and six billion dollars in 2019
and as of 2020 it's expected that ninety
percent of all organizations in the
world would be using cloud services not
to mention several organizations around
the world suggest that using cloud
computing services has enabled their
employees to experiment a lot more with
technologies like machine learning and
artificial intelligence so here's what
we'll be going through today firstly
we'll be talking about who is a cloud
computing engineer the steps you need to
take to become a cloud computing
engineer and the cloud computing
engineer salaries so first off who is a
cloud computing engineer now a cloud
computing engineer is an IT professional
who takes care of all the technical
aspects of cloud computing now be a
design planning maintenance and support
now a cloud computing engineer can take
up a number of different career paths
this could be that of a cloud developer
security engineer a full-stack developer
sis ops administrator Solutions
Architect cloud architect and so much
more now let's have a look at some of
the major cloud computing roles first
off we have Solutions Architect now
these are individuals who are
responsible for analyzing the technical
environment in which they are going to
produce the solutions the requirements
and the specifications secondly they are
required to select an appropriate
technology that satisfies set
requirements they need to estimate and
manage the usage and the operational
costs of the solutions they provide and
they need to support project management
as well as
Lucian development next we have sis ops
administrators they are involved in
deploying managing and operating highly
scalable and fault-tolerant systems they
need to select an appropriate service
based on compute security or data
requirements they need to estimate and
manage usage and operational costs and
they need to be able to migrate
on-premises workloads on to an
appropriate cloud computing platform so
among both of these roles there are
certain requirements that are remaining
constant now let's have a look at the
steps you need to take to become a cloud
computing engineer your first step is to
gain proficiency in a cloud computing
platform now the first step is to become
proficient in at least one of the three
major cloud computing platforms beat AWS
Azure or the Google cloud platform now
there are a huge number of resources
that you can find on the Internet it
could be YouTube videos articles virtual
or physical classrooms and so much more
now after you're done learning you can
get certified by Microsoft as your AWS
or the Google cloud platform now for AWS
you have a number of different
certifications which can be divided into
three categories which are the
foundational which is just the basics
the associate level certifications the
professional level certifications and
the speciality certifications similarly
with Microsoft is your year
certifications that enable you to become
an azure developer associate and a co
administrator associate an azure
Architect professional and a DevOps
engineer now most cloud computing
platforms have a free tier that you can
take advantage of these provide a number
of free services for a period of time
some of which are free forever so you
can use these platforms to your
advantage and do as much practice as you
can on them now if you want to learn
more about cloud computing you can also
check out simple loans YouTube channel
then you can go on to the playlist
section right here and you can find
comprehensive videos on a number of
different cloud computing platforms AWS
and Microsoft Azure our AWS tutorial
videos talk about what exactly is AWS
how you can become an AW Solutions
Architect
Amazon ec2 s3 some of the other services
and so much more we also have detailed
tutorials on Azure which talks about
what exactly is your the certifications
provided by Azure some
the services like machine learning as
your Active Directory and so much more
and now we're at step to being
experienced in at least one programming
language unlike general-purpose
programming languages like C C++ C sharp
and so on cloud computing requires once
there are a lot more data oriented now
some of the major programming languages
that are used in cloud computing are go
Python closure and Java now as I said
before there is a wealth of resources
that you can learn from there are free
websites that you can practice your code
on like quick code code Academy and
several others there's also resources
like YouTube videos as well as there's
the option of online or offline classes
now we're at step 3
specialization you'll also need to be
well-versed with a number of key
concepts these are storage and
networking
now with storage you need to know how
data can be stored and where it can be
accessed from you need to know how it
can be accessed from multiple different
resources you'll also need to have some
experience with the services provided by
as your and either Bleus like the Amazon
s3 in AWS and the appropriately named
Azure storage from Microsoft's EUR with
networking you need to have a strong
understanding of the networking
fundamentals as well as virtual networks
next up we have virtual ization and
operating systems with virtualization
you need to know how virtual networks
which is just a combination of different
virtual machines can be used to emulate
different components in a particular
system with operating systems you need
to have a very strong understanding
operating systems like Windows and Linux
next up we have security and disaster
recovery now you need to understand how
data our application as well as
infrastructure can be protected from
malicious attacks disaster recovery you
need to be prepared for any unexpected
circumstance by making sure your systems
are always safe and are regularly backed
up to prevent any sort of loss of data
then we have web services and DevOps now
you need to have a strong understanding
of api's or application program
interfaces and web services some amount
of experience with web design also can
be of great help with DevOps you need to
have a strong understanding of how cloud
computing is able to provide a sense
platform on which you can perform
testing deployment and production for
DevOps automation maroa with DevOps you
understand the synergy that the
operations as well as the development
teams have with each other and for the
success of any project and finally
you're a cloud computing engineer now
let's have a look at the salaries of
cloud computing engineers in the United
States cloud computing engineers earn
around one hundred sixteen thousand
dollars per annum in India a cloud
computing engineer is paid approximately
six lakhs sixty six thousand rupees per
annum now how can simply learn helped
you become a cloud computing engineer so
let's head on to simple Yuans website
here we have the cloud architect
master's program now this deals with a
number of different courses all of which
I can help you get started in your
journey to becoming a cloud computing
engineer this master's program covers a
number of different courses like AWS
technical essentials Microsoft Azure
fundamentals AWS developer associate and
so much more it provides you 40-plus
in-demand skills and 25 plus services
provides you a master certification it
has 16 plus real-life projects and helps
you get a salary that ranges between 15
to 25 lakh rupees per annum it also
covers a variety of tools like Amazon
ec2 as your data factory washing
machines and so much more
so why don't you head on to simply learn
comm and get started on your journey to
getting certified and getting ahead and
with that we've reached the end of this
video I hope you guys found this video
informative and helpful thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simpler
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here